[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
executive director here at the long now
foundation as many of you know we start
these talks with what we call a long
short a short film that exemplifies long
term thinking usually on the theme of
the evenings talk and this one was a was
an interesting search to find the right
one but we saw this clip from chasing
ice which if you haven't seen is a
really amazing movie on putting up
multi-year time-lapse cameras in the
most difficult environments in the world
and one of the things they caught was a
Manhattan sized Calvin event which seems
apropos for this evening enjoy
I'm on the phone with Jim on one of our
regular check-ins Jim just nothing's
happening it's going well we had some
serious bouts of wind but other than
that things are fairly well set up here
we've got it's starting at him
I think hot on it starting let me call
you back okay yeah for that c-section
right there holy [ __ ] look at that big
bird rolling
look at that
you see how look at the whole thing
the calving phases 300 sometimes 400
feet tall pieces of ice we're shooting
up out of the ocean 600 feet and then
falling
the only way that you can really try to
put it in the scale with human
references if you imagine a Manhattan
and all of a sudden all of those
buildings just start to rumble and quake
and peel off and just fall over and fall
over and roll around this whole massive
city just breaking apart in front of
your office
we're just observers these two little
dots on the side of the mouth we watched
and recorded the largest witness cam
Univ n ever caught on tape so how big
was this calving event that we just
looked at will resort to some
illustrations again to give you a sense
of scale it's as if the entire lower tip
of Manhattan broke off except that the
thickness the height of it is equivalent
to buildings that are two-and-a-half or
three times higher than they are
you
that's a magical miraculous horrible
scary thing I don't know that anybody's
really seeing the miracle and horror of
that
it took a hundred years for it to
retreat eight miles from 1900 to 2000
from 2000 to 2010 it retreated nine
miles so in ten years
it retreated more than it had in the
previous 100
[Music]
you
[Music]
well that was appropriately geological
and it gives you a sense of scale and
majesty and yet ice calving is a it's
romantic because it's a quick and
terrifying a beautiful event and
peculiarity of climate changes it is
gradual and slow and inexorable and goes
on for decades and centuries and we're
used to seeing problems in terms in a
y2k or something that's gonna come in
five years we're gonna fix it before it
happens and turns out there wasn't a
problem after all but quick problems
quick solutions this is not a quick
problem it's slow its enormous its
inexorable but as climatologist Stephen
Schneider pointed out to me you watch
things and any of the signals you're
watching if they're less than ten years
they're not climate yet there's weather
like the current California drought is
in that category so to see the problem
in the long term frame then gives you a
chance to see any potential solutions
almost certainly have to be in a
long-term frame and if you imagine
you're going to do something sudden and
quick that will somehow solve the
problem you don't understand the problem
someone who does understand the problem
and it's thinking about the solution in
the problem strands is David Keith thank
you
thank you very much it's really a
pleasure to be here and and thank you
very much Stuart for not just the invite
but also for encouraging the title the
patient geoengineering title because
it's helped me to crystallize some of
the way I've been thinking about this
problem in a way that really feels new
so let me start first with a very simple
background on what the idea is and then
I'll plunge into a bunch of what I think
my biases are and how how we might
consider this wacky idea the basic idea
of solar geoengineering is the idea that
we could partially and imperfectly
reduce some of the risks of climate
change that come from the accumulation
of greenhouse gases in the atmosphere by
putting reflective aerosols say sulfuric
acid a pollutant in the stratosphere
where it would reflect away a little bit
of sunlight say 1% of the peak that's
really the core idea and this idea has a
kind of terrifying leverage in the sense
that a gram of these aerosols in the
stratosphere roughly offsets the climate
force are forcing as we say of a ton of
carbon dioxide in the lower atmosphere
it doesn't eliminate the problem but it
masks some of it and that's a ratio of a
million to one
I like the ratio of chemical weapons to
nuclear weapons so it's that scale of
thing that we're dealing with for better
or for worse I'm gonna start start with
some explanation of my personal biases
and see if I can get my time or the work
here there we go
so first nature
over the last 10 millennia especially
over the last century humanity has
caused what in my view is a kind of
environmental Holocaust lots of things I
love that's a bias I come into it with
it there's different ways to look at
that problem and that's how I look at it
there's all sorts of things we can't go
visit anymore
Moiz these wonderful huge flightless
birds that used to be in New Zealand
woolly mammoths you name it
tall grass prairie that used to be where
Chicago now stands etc and rapid climate
change will help to drive a nail into
what's left because it's hard for the
world to adapt to all the changes we
made through most more than any other
single thing through agriculture
actually and then put rapid climate
changes on top of it
I've been lucky personally and this
doesn't give me any special insight it's
just a useful bias to have spent a lot
of time in the big wild so I've done a
bunch of trips this is a month-long trip
on North Baffin Island I did with two
friends I've done quite a few of these
long trips that picture before was from
a kayak and Antarctica and and I've had
some sense of the this this big
wilderness and it means a lot but it
also raises a kind of obvious paradox
so most people assume that somebody who
cares about the environment wouldn't
think about engineering the whole thing
that those are naturally antagonistic
viewpoints and a central thing I want to
convince you about is that it's not
simple and that that even though one's
instant reaction is that the kind of
classic environmental values
many of us have would suggest that we
shouldn't do something like this that in
fact given the actual trade-offs we face
it might be the sound thing to do so I
said a little bit about what I think has
happened to parts of the remaining
natural environment but I also think
it's important to say what my biases are
about what the risk to people are so
it's now become quite common to imagine
that climate poses some kind of
existential threat to humanity I don't
buy it I think there are lots of big
threats to humanity but I don't think
climate is one and not in a simple way
anyway first of all there's a tendency
to see everything as as going to hell
but I think it's important to say that
in many ways the last century or two
have been amazing for humanity less
hunger less violence even counting the
big Wars
last century less violence that we've
seen per capita in in millenia bless
ignorance more art lots of things for
humans have gone right and I think the
big threat to humans is not climate
change but other humans you know you
name it
bio weapons killer robots nuclear
weapons I mean I'm being saying killer
world us to be flipped but meaning the
IT that people the the information
technologies that people partly in this
town our area are inventing or
potentially lethal to humanity so I
think those are the things that they
pose really really existential threats
not not climate change so gia sharing is
is ugly and the fact that we're
considering something like solar geo is
sharing now does represent a kind of
colossal failure of governance at least
the way we are now considering it and
and as I said many people believe it's
scary my goal is to convince you that it
cannot be casually dismissed that that
there are hard trade-offs here about
whether or not we do it and that's true
even almost wherever you come from in
terms of kind of shared values about the
environment so I'm gonna take this in a
few steps ranging from the kind of big
picture to their really geeky minutiae
thinking that there will be some
scientist in the audience so let me
start with a story about scenarios it
turns out that with this as with many
other technologies a huge part of how
you view it of how effective or
ineffective it might be of how risky it
is depends not on the inherent technical
features of the thing itself but on how
we use it how much we use it how quickly
we use it so let's start with scenarios
um these are a little much a hand-drawn
sketches here they have roughly the
right numbers on them but it's they're
hand drawn because the truth is we're
making a lot of this stuff up especially
about the future so I could give you
model results from postdoctoral fellows
that show you what carbon
oxide concentrations will be to six
significant digits in 2100 but we don't
know and this thing called
business-as-usual of course is not
likely to be usual and exactly what will
happen over the next hundred years we
don't know very well so that's one of
the reasons I like these hand-drawn
sketches but so what this is on the
vertical axis is emissions of carbon in
in billions of tons a year so now we're
admitting close to 10 billion tons a
year and it's just going up like a
rocket we have lots of meetings about
climate change we like to talk about it
but we haven't made any appreciable
impact on emissions so let's say we had
a kind of clean green revolution that
drove emissions down towards zero over
one human lifetime which if we want a
stable climate we ought to do and we can
do so let's say we do that great thing
we might even have a super clean green
revolution and drive emissions under
zero it's completely possible to do that
we can talk about how we might do that
and then that would actually have some
negative emissions in it along with
driving emissions to zero that's all
good but it's worth thinking about what
this means to the climate because
climate does not respond directly to the
day-to-day emissions of carbon dioxide
it responds to the accumulation of that
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere over
decades to millennia carbon dioxide by
some measures lasts and long on the
atmospheres is nuclear waste you look at
the difference between waste one year
from from release or a reactor to a
thousand years out the radioactivity is
down by a factor of a thousand whew emit
carbon dioxide as we've been doing by
extracting fossil fuels in the ground
and burning them if you admit that with
an exponentially increasing rate and
then suddenly stop a thousand years
later you've still got roughly half the
warming you had at the peak so there's a
very long problem this way so what this
shows you is not the emissions per year
but it shows you a measure of the
climate risk measured in a thing called
radiative forcing which is how we like
to think about it and the key point here
is that the business-as-usual as obvious
the blue curve is what happens if we
bring emissions to zero of course behind
the blue curve on the previous plot
all that bringing emissions to zero does
it's it stops making the problem worse
which is a big deal but that's what it
does doesn't make it better if you want
to start making the problem gradually
better the green curve which corresponds
to us taking some co2 out of the air
does that but it's slow it's inherently
a very slow process that's why these are
drawn out to twenty two hundred so a
common view about solar Chima shearing
is that we do it in order to compensate
for all of the co2 induced climate
change so we make it go away and we keep
happily admitting co2 forever that's a
terrible idea
and if that's what solar team you're
hearing is I don't want any part of it
the the question is are the more
reasonable scenarios for its use one
other comment that's made is once we do
it at all we have to keep doing it
forever for ten millennia sir that's the
only way it's useful no let's say we did
it in a way like I've shown here we
gradually wrap it up over a century and
then wrap it back down the amount of
this turning down the Sun this
offsetting of the climate impact of the
accumulated greenhouse gases that we
offset by this deliberate introduction
of some fancy particles I'll show you
some ideas about that later
fancy particles say into the
stratosphere so the net effect of that
offsetting is that you slow down the
rate of change that's useful a whole lot
of the environmental risk not all but a
significant part of the environmental
risks happen from rate of change so even
if you just do this minimal thing it's
absolutely true that you do nothing to
improve the climate in 2200 under this
scenario it's just as bad as it would
have been if you hadn't done solar
Jewish cheering but what you have done
is make everything happen more slowly
and that's a benefit gives plants and
animals more time to adapt it gives us
more chance to to deal with the problem
in various ways so there's a core
benefit even there now that scenario
kind of assumed that our knowledge of
the world and our values and political
system stays constant that's not likely
so you can draw
these pictures is fun to draw them but
maybe in 2050 we find that Greenland
really is going to collapse or maybe
it's not new science we don't find out
that the client problem is worse than we
thought but maybe we have a kind of
social revolutionary change in values
that say we care much more than than
many of us seem to know about really
reducing the climate footprints of
humanity so whatever it is we might
change what we're doing and if we do
that we could do something more quick so
this would be some scenario where we do
a lot more geoengineering and then work
harder to take co2 out of the air and
then you have some kind of
geoengineering wedge you might call it
and and that goes on for sort of 200-300
years not ten thousand years a few long
human lifetimes that's the kind of
commitment we're talking about but it's
a commitment that we're talking about
with carbon dioxide no matter what what
is new and different here is this gives
you a chance to substantially reduce the
climate risks and the climate impacts
both to humans too vulnerable humans and
ecosystems over a single human lifetime
but not a weak none of this is a
one-week problem it's a slow problem and
in a scenario like this you first have
peak temperatures the peak temperatures
happen at roughly the peak of this
so-called radiative forcing the amount
we're pushing the climate from the
combined effects of co2 pushing it warm
and and and the geoengineering effect
pushing it cold and then you have later
peak carbon the peak emissions point and
then the pgo ensuring point after that
that's kind of deep for these scenarios
so in thinking about the scenarios I've
come to think about three key things one
is that I think we want to think about
this as being temporary we don't want to
commit to do this for 10,000 years
because I can't even begin to think that
far in advance but we can think a
hundred years in advance some people who
are skeptics to this say Oh humanity
can't possibly do anything for a hundred
years but we've had transatlantic
telecommunications for more than a
hundred years we've had electric power
systems for more than 100 years humanity
actually does have some ability even
through big Wars to manage to
do things at a sustained way and I think
there's a reason to believe that if we
want to we could do better
second thing is at least to be
responsive and third moderate I'm gonna
take response of a little later in this
talk but let me talk about what I mean
by moderate as I said much of the work
that's been done on this topic assumes
that that we use geoengineering to do
all the work to do compensate for all
the climate risks that you can do of the
co2 in the atmosphere and I think that's
I don't know apply what I say it's nuts
but it's in fact the basis of most of
the work on this topic and let me try
and show you why it's nuts so let's say
that you can adjust the amount of solar
generation sharing which in this case is
shown by how much you turn down the Sun
and hypothetically in percents so as you
begin to do that there's some benefit
you get from the reduced climate changes
on the ground reduced changing
temperature reduced changes in
precipitation reduction in ice sheets
melting for example those are all the
benefits are doing that the benefits of
course are reduced harms it's masking
like a band-aid the harm that's come
from the accumulated greenhouse gases
over the the centuries of human
industrial civilization now it's clear
that if you turn up this eventually
things start getting worse the benefits
go away indeed just to set the scale
here to give you a sense of how big the
leverage is climate models suggest and
not just climb models are basic to your
physical theory that if you if you turn
down the Sun by 8 percent for a century
you freeze the oceans to the equator has
happened probably in the neoproterozoic
the chunk of a billion years ago and
that would extinguish all life on land
except the deep ocean and that happened
in Earth history not because somebody
was messing with the climate but but
that has happened and that gives you a
sense of the kind of extraordinary and
and frightening power that humanity is
gradually developing over the natural
world and I don't celebrate that but I
don't think we should well I don't think
we'll make good decisions if we pretend
that we don't have it that's a power
that we're developing
not because we set out to do it but
largely for other reasons but it's a
real power and a frightening one in any
case forget that kind of crazy scenario
for a second these are these are the the
way the benefits look and then the risks
the damages so there are all sorts of
side effects I'll get to them in a
second but but if you put sulfur gas in
the stratosphere for example you could
deplete stratospheric ozone in fact
that's a topic I work on a bunch of show
you a little bit on that later a whole
bunch of risks and damages in general
the risks get worse pretty quickly as
you do more of it so if you ask yourself
how much you should do it's very
unlikely the amount you should do is
where the you choose the peak benefits
it's much more likely that you choose
somewhere down lower down where you get
quite a lot of benefit and not so much
risk and there's another I think sort of
political reason to think about using
solar jima sharing in a moderate way to
only deal with some of the climate risk
because we want there to be a strong
political rationale for and benefit for
continuing to cut emissions so indeed
one of the specific scenarios I'll show
you in a second is that we use this
technology to cut in half the rate of
climate change not to cut to zero to cut
in half in case that's the kind of core
argument about about moderation so
temporary responsive and moderate in a
word that the Stuart's gesture for this
patient not a quick fix not a magic fix
at all something that helps us to
moderate the damages so I've given you a
very sort of generic version of this
here's something that gets a little bit
more specific you could suppose the goal
is to reduce the rate of climate change
by half starting in 2020 from what we
can tell this is technically an
achievable goal do I really think this
will happen politically no I think it's
very unlikely but I think it's credible
that one could do that and have time to
do appropriate checking of the risks
given the fact that that the rate at
which you grow the amount of generations
very slow so if you start in 2020 even
by 2040 you're actually doing a
remarkably small amount the method the
most basic method that we understand the
best is this this idea of putting
sulfuric gas in the stratosphere and all
I'll show you in a minute that there's
other things we could do that might be
less risky but we don't know them so
well to do that you'd have to start a
really intensive scientific program now
in technical program and also program to
understand how we regulate this
technology right now I think the most
important thing to do is to break the
kind of inbred nature of this debate
there's been a quite small number of
people working on this technology and I
think there's a real risk of groupthink
that I am part of and I think if we want
the larger public to take this seriously
if we want to make decisions that affect
the whole planet we have to break that
we have to have a much wider scientific
engagement with how this works
it doesn't I've given you something
specific about the technologies to do it
we've actually commissioned some studies
to understand how to do it and the
frightening thing is that it's
fantastically cheap you couldn't do this
for a cost that's of order a billion a
year which sounds like a lot but the
cost of climate damages are a trillion a
year by mid-century the cost of cutting
emissions are a trillium year those are
the kind of numbers that we're talking
about and so a numbers like a billion
are tiny that doesn't mean that we
should do it just because it's cheap it
means that I'll come back to this again
and again it's a risk to risk decision
there are risks of doing it the risks of
not doing it but it's not the cost of
doing it there will be the issue it also
raises the possibility of unilateral
action so so even potentially small
states could do it so there are lots of
ways in which having it be cheap is bad
but it does appear to be a fact so just
for the record you can go find a paper
that says some of this and this is a
relatively plain language paper but
still somewhat technical it came out
yesterday so next I want to talk about
efficacy about how well this thing could
work I haven't said anything about that
yet and it's really one of the if
there's one technical part of this
presentation I want you to to to hear or
to take away from its this
so what I mean by efficacy so it's
useful to think about two completely
different sort of aspects of this one is
if you turn up the amount of carbon
dioxide as we've been doing as humanity
you warm up the planet and make all
sorts of other change it's not just
warming you make it wetter in some
places dry on others you can potentially
make the big ice sheets melt etc climate
change is a complicated multifaceted
thing it's not just temperature it's
clear that if you turn down the Sun
you'll obviously don't really turn down
the Sun but it reflect away a little
more sunlight to have the effect of
turning down the Sun climate modelers
can turn on the Sun by adjusting one
constant in their model if you do that
it's obvious that you can force the
global surface temperatures back to
pre-industrial if you wanted to in
theory but that doesn't mean that the
climate comes back to pre-industrial the
question is does this do anything
meaningful for the climate because the
climate is complicated multifaceted
thing so this question of efficacy is in
theory if you could and we could not
don't let it you can or not if you could
reflect away some sunlight will you
meaningfully reduce actual climate risk
we care about you know like risk status
that places will get inundated by salt
water
risk that high temperatures will damage
crops and make it harder for for some of
the more vulnerable in the world to feed
themselves those are the risks we
actually want to address and the
question is does this address it and
then any specific way that we go about
doing this like sulfates in the
stratosphere but there's a bunch of
other ways making a concert and kind of
marine cloud brighter might work there's
other things other than sulfates have
strata straight we'll get to in a second
those those there are specific risks
that are contingent on the way we do it
so let me get to efficacy for a second
and I'm gonna show you a vector diagram
some of you will have seen this back in
school some not I'll talk you through it
so climate models are linear so if you
if you double the amount of radiative
forcing of co2 in the atmosphere you get
kind of twice the response whether the
real world is like that is not so clear
but but it's pretty clear that models
are like that so models have lots of
different places now I'm being a little
glib there's actually some
to believe that in some respects those
models are right and after all it's
precisely those models that are the
central thing we use to understand what
the risks are of accumulating co2 in the
atmosphere so an obvious objection all
the stuff I'm saying about solar we're
hearing is how can you know anything
you've just got models but they're the
same models and same deep scientific
understanding we have that tells us
something about the risks of accumulated
co2 in the atmosphere so let's say we
have two regions this could be San
Francisco temperature and New York
rainfall just two variables in the model
if you as the amount of co2 increases
both those things change in some ratio
I'm calling you know region B could be
San Francisco temperature and region a
is New York rainfall if you adjust the
amount of solar gene sharing the red
line you can you can choose how long
that red line is every 2 or 3 years we
get to choose how much software we put
in the atmosphere for a year more like
it
but what you don't know is whether the
lines oppose each other so you can
choose it like that or maybe you could
make the red line longer this makes
everything good for B but leaves a to
warm or too wet or whatever it happens
to be so this gets up there kind of
trade-offs in inequality the fact that
this thing doesn't exactly do it if the
red arrow exactly opposed the blue arrow
then this would be perfect fix but
turning down the Sun is not anti co2 one
of the most obvious ways that is true is
ocean acidification so carbon co2 in the
atmosphere doesn't just change the
climate it changes the geochemistry the
planet changes the way plants grow
changes the way coral reefs will grow
and in fact will make them grow a lot
less that's potion acidification solar
generation does almost nothing about
that topic very little directly so
that's some pictures you could maybe
think of some optimum there's lots of
economics you could do about the
trade-offs I and several other people
have written lots of papers about how
this is a very unequal thing and there's
big trade-offs so then we thought to
actually check for models how unequal it
was and one way to get at the
inequalities to say simply what is the
angle between these two vectors and and
you can do this in many dimensional
space in our paper we did in a 44
dimensional space big deal
the bottom line is a measure of how well
it works is what the angle is if the
angle was the way I drew it here then
solar generation would do nothing to
make climate better it will just be a
different climate forcing co2 would be
pushing the planet this way and solar to
our Charon pushing another way and it
wouldn't really be reducing any risk it
would just be making new risks so the
question is what's the angle and if
you'd asked me to guess before we did
this my guess would have been like 45
degrees it's useful maybe it can sort of
cut some of the risk by half or square
root two but that's about it the actual
result from models is much better than
that natural angle is a few degrees 10
degrees or something so that for some
variables you can on a region by region
basis for precipitation and temperature
you can reduce the changes in models by
a lot by like 80% if there's a one
reason to take this idea seriously this
is it there are lots of reasons this
might not quite be true there are lots
of caveats there are lots of political
risks but there's an underlying reason
why this conversation is still going on
why people reluctantly and even though
they in many ways hate the idea are
taking this idea seriously this is it
there really seems to be a prospect that
there's an achievable way to
substantially reduce the climate risk
for most of the world in one lifetime so
let's talk a little bit more about risks
at high technology
I'll go a little bit faster here maybe
slightly less important so I've talked
about sulfur and stratosphere the
obvious thing I want to show you one
piece of really new research not even
submitted for publication yet and that
is about alternative particles in the
stratosphere and it gives you a sense of
the fact that the idea that people think
is Jewish hearing is the idea that has
been around actually for 30 or 40 years
the first high quality report to the US
government that really reached the top
decision maker in the country about
climate change was a report to President
Johnson in 1965 I was two years old and
that report
really got a lot of it right it got the
fundamental fact right which is that if
we keep digging fossil fuels from
underground and putting them in the
atmosphere we will change the climate
deeply and the only suggestion have had
for fixing it was what we now call solar
geoengineering so so these ideas are not
new and the sulfate idea has been around
for decades but because there's been
such a strong taboo against doing any
research about this because people have
been so scared with good reason but I
think ultimately not correctly had been
so scared to even talk about it
there's been no funded research inside
this in the end just do what they're
funded to do so people put very little
effort into thinking about new ways to
do this so I'll show you some new ways
the first paper about this actually is
by quite a crowd Edward Teller no less
and others that lowers Livermore have a
really cute paper that shows you how a
bunch of solid particles that is not a
liquid droplet I should say why sulfuric
acid actually a droplet of water in the
stratosphere reflects sunlight away fine
almost as well as a drop of sulfuric
acid
the reason not to use water is water and
the stratosphere evaporates very quickly
the only reason the acid is there is to
prevent the water from evaporating and
it builds on what nature does because
big volcanoes do this that's how we know
about it but so fear gas the
stratosphere and cool the climate down
so teller and Co thought of better ways
to do this I thought of some other cool
ways to have levitated discs that
there's been a bunch of other papers
about these solids but all these papers
have been very theoretical they've been
just assuming that we're magic Sol's in
a stratosphere but in the real
stratosphere there's the natural sulfate
and the sulfate particles will hit the
solids and coat them and sulfate can
destroy ozone and if it's coated thinly
on solids it can destroy ozone even
worse and so we've built a model that
actually deals with the solid and liquid
aerosols together and does the chemistry
in a reasonable way and here's some
fancy slides I won't show you about
ozone depletion and now I'm going to get
to trade-offs so this thing shows you
the kind of one of the key trade-offs
you want ideally what you'd want is the
ability to make Radia forcing and not
make any loss of ozone
we don't want less ozone ideally what
you
really want is the ability to make some
radio forcing that's the solar to
English or anything and restore the
ozone layer remember the ozone layer has
been damaged by the chlorofluorocarbons
that we put in it
the ozone-depleting chemicals that we've
banned in the most successful
environmental treaty of all time and
Montreal Protocol but but those things
are still there and they're still
damaging the ozone layer and we'd
ideally like to restore it we actually
have ways that that might be possible
but the question is trade-offs
so the standard sulfur scheme the people
have written about forever if you want
to do some amount say two watts per
square meter which is amount people talk
about for solar cheering you end up
depleting in our model which actually is
worse for ozone than most of them we
deplete the the overall ozone by 10
percent which is quite a bit so we
fooled around with new particles this is
a Lumina which is you know may be better
in some ways but these were small
alumina particles and they're terrible
they don't really do anything
for cooling the planet down and they're
great just trying ozone so that's an
example it didn't work but I thought you
got to show the examples that didn't
work this is slightly bigger alumina
particles these are much bigger alumina
particles and we've also been playing
with Diamond which is a little better
because it doesn't heat the stratosphere
it turns out and the bottom line is
these new particles even counting all
the ozone chemistry and now doing a
bunch of stuff people haven't done
before look like you can get this same
amount of turning down the Sun effect
with about half as much ozone loss which
is certainly better although you'd like
to do better still I just want to give
you a sense of sort of new ideas you
don't need to read all the details here
but the key thing is that what woodlot
what we'd like to do is find safe and
testable ways to put something say in
the stratosphere that would reflect away
this kind of half of 1% or 1% of
sunlight and ideally you'd like it not
to deplete ozone you'd like it not to
make much diffuse light which is a
problem with sulfates
you'd like it not to heat the lower
stratosphere which is a problem because
it could get more water and lower
stratosphere which causes all sorts of
itself and you know there's evidence
that we could achieve all of those but
it's a kind of the advantage of sulfur's
the devil we know
so nature does that and that also gives
us a lot of confidence
beyond models an obvious question is you
know why should we trust you
long haired nut jobs you've built all
these malls in your lab how do you know
anything and I think that's a wise of
you one of the things that's good about
the sulfuric acid scheme is we have
experience from nature so if you look at
the suggestions that I anothers had made
about how we might gradually do solar
generation hearing even after 50 years
of cutting the the global rate of
climate change roughly in half the
amount of sulfur we put in the
stratosphere would be about 1 million
tons so that a bigger small number means
nothing if I just say that to you
probably but Mount Pinatubo eruption one
of the volcanoes that put a lot of
sulfur and stress here and cooled the
climate put 8 million tons in one year
so we'd be about 1/8 of that and that
means that we have a lot of kind of
empirical confidence from the
observations of Pinatubo that the
results would not be disaster if they're
not some kind of unknown unknown that's
huge it's out there to get us because
nature's actually put much more than
that
whereas with diamond particles they look
better in theory but maybe there's
something we're not thinking about and
the question is how could you actually
go test I and colleagues at Harvard
who've done a lot of the pioneering work
actually understanding the chemistry of
the ozone hole have built instruments
that we've flown on balloons of how to
the aircraft to measure to the ozone
chemistry and we've now been thinking
about and proposing but not doing yet
experiments that would do this with
sulfuric acid particles or other
particles and would measure some of
these key characteristics of how much
things we might put in the stratosphere
would say cause ozone loss a common
statement about this is you can't test
anything about geoengineering unless you
tested at full scale that's nonsense you
can't test everything but you can test a
lot the scale of this experiment
who is to release about a hundred grams
of sulfate so that's about as much as a
commercial aircraft does in one minute
of flight so this experiment may or may
not be useful it may not make may or may
not be cost-effective you ma'am and I
think it should be done but it'd be very
hard to argue that it's spectacularly
risky if it's putting a hundred grams of
sulfur in the stratosphere it gives you
some sense of of a pathway forward so if
one actually wanted to have a sustained
program to do this you wouldn't just
decide to turn on the switch indeed
here's the sort of simplest version of
this statement if you gave me a choice
to do solar geoengineering at full scale
or to abandon it forever I would choose
abandon it forever the only way this
makes sense is if you gradually work
your way up gradually work your way up
through a series of tests and
experiments that are just bitter done
you know sort of scientifically open
fashion around the world and then by
gradually if if you decide to go further
by gradually ramping up the amount that
you put in and observing as you go
we don't predict things very well in
advance we do a good job if we learn as
we go so now I want to say a little bit
about control and understanding I
haven't said so much about that an
obvious question is how the heck can you
control a system or engineer a system
you don't understand we'll never
understand everything about the whole
climate it's complex
unpredictable system the answer is
feedback there are lots of systems that
we routinely control from agriculture to
human diseases to complicated machines
where we don't understand everything
about them but we control them because
we observe and modify as we go
and that's crucial to a kind of patience
flow approach to solar geoengineering
so this is a very geeky slide I first
made actually for Steve Schneider's
birthday 15 years ago and got a start on
this whole line of research so you've
all know that at some level weather is
chaotic and this is what chaos means
I'll both those quickly and the
assumption is you can't control
chaotic systems in fact we routinely
control chaotic systems indeed we build
deliberately chaotic systems because you
can control them with small control
system inputs for those of you who if
that's all Greek you could ignore it for
a second I'll go it's like me I have an
even more geeky slide and then get a
little more down to some example that
may make sense so this is the more geeky
slide about feedback if you like the
bottom line is we've tried doing
feedback in climate models and the key
point is we can assume that we don't
know exactly how effective say putting
sulfur in a stratosphere is we can make
the feedback loop be tuned up on one
client model and then apply it to
another so sort of trying to simulate
the fact that we have a lot of ignorance
and we simulate all the uncertainty in
the observation system and the fact that
we don't can't measure things very well
and yet with appropriate feedback we can
still manage to do in a model some
measure of control of say global
precipitation or global temperature so
there's a problem if you don't do
feedback right and that gets to kind of
one of the core risks and the chorus of
the interaction and it's the difference
between a kind of technocratic calm
approach and the real-world approach so
let me let me give you an analogy first
pilot induced oscillations or what
happens in aircraft when the pilot
turned when the aircraft turns one way
the pilot turns the other way to try and
correct it and then that correction is
too slow and the over corrects and then
corrects back this happens have a lots
of times but it happened in particular
in the American Airlines flight 587 it
was about a couple minutes into flight
pilot went through a some turbulent air
and they corrected the rudder back and
forth several times over 20 seconds all
the way from one side together the
rudder others with your feet sorry and
broke the rudder off and the airplane
crashed 265 people killed or so there
are several elements this thing that I
think are a very close analogy to the
kind of problems we could have as a
species time to control something like
measuring so so there's several so it's
worth explaining the rudder pedals are
made deliberately sticky so that pilots
won't kind of accidentally bump the
rudder pedals too easily so it's a
breakout force you have to push it hard
enough to get the thing moving and and
so part of what happened is the pilot
pushed one way had to push hard and then
push the other way pushed back and forth
until until he wiggled the plane back
and forth and broke off the rudder so
the plane designer smirked um that was
those there was a good reason to that
design the pilot wasn't stupid he was
actually doing what he'd been trying to
do oh that training didn't correctly
match the aircraft dynamics and the
pilots reaction time was natural but the
result was a fatality everybody killed
and that message I think is powerful so
if we actually tried to climb an
engineering the the individual pieces
can be right but you can still have a
disastrous outcome in the combination
and we've fool around with simulating
that so this is the same simulation I
showed you before but now with a
two-year time delay if you imagine
politicians deciding how much fuel
ensuring they should do and take some
two years to make a decision then in the
same model that I showed you before we
got a good answer in this answer we
oscillate just the same way so that's
the that's the that's the bad answer and
these are these are still kind of
imagining you can have the whole world
in the computer obviously that's in many
ways a kind of a technocratic and narrow
vision on the flight over here actually
I got to watch Earl Morris's great
documentary on mcnamara about vietnam
and he sore he's a smart self-critical
person but largely fails to connect with
the core reality of decisions they made
in vietnam and our models are useful
they gave us tools but these tools are
deeply imperfect and they can't predict
many of the real surprises we've had in
the political world from you know follow
the civil union rise of the internet etc
and certainty is deep so in the last
section I want to talk a little bit
about fear is the obvious thing and some
optimism so I think a central problem a
central concern
this whole idea is best expressed with
this cartoon and yeah the punchline
these cartoons is always the guy right
at the very bottom
so yeah the search for breakthrough
technology and it's a time machine that
sets us back 50 years when we should
have put a price on carbon and the
little guide the bottom says we better
hurry that a guy says no no it's a great
thing about a time machine you don't
have to hurry and and that is part of
the gotcha
with this geoengineering is the idea
that is this kind of addictive idea that
it allows you to it's almost go back in
time in the sense that as we burn more
fossil fuels we just make the climate
worse and this allows you to go back in
perfectly a little bit in time and that
tempts you to be more lazy about making
the climate worse that's really one of
the central risks so I showed you a
version of this before again this this
business as usual is is a it's a it's a
collective hallucination I think one of
the dirty secrets of climate policy
analysis is that it's easy to show big
progress against business as usual if
you control the counterfactual business
as usual we have no way to know what it
really is I just wanna it's really
important to say that so anyway that's
business as usual if you bring emissions
to zero you get something like this if
you're bringing emissions to zero more
aggressively more quickly you have
better client policy build more solar
panels more nuclear power plants
whatever you do that working harder
means losing less badly without
geoengineering all you get from climate
policy is you lose less you solute leave
you lose slower and that's a hard
message to sell I'm no PR expert but I
think a fundamental thing that's hard
about climate policy is that the the
main message has been one of despair and
that if we work really hard we'll be a
little less despairing I don't want it
to sound like I'm saying geoengineering
gets a magic solution it does not but it
may get us a more soft landing in
combination with cutting image
and that's a more helpful answer and
that's that's the core piece so first of
all this is the wedge that's
conservation efficiency decarbonisation
and maybe even carbon removal and
exactly how big that wedge is depends on
where business-as-usual is but the point
is you must in the end bring emissions
to zero if you want to stable climate
nothing that I've told you about
geoengineering changes that if you want
a stable climb in the long run God are
bringing emissions to zero the only
question is how quickly then once you've
done that you've got this choice of how
much you want to remove carbon which is
inherently a slow process because
there's a lot of carbon there's no magic
quick fix to do that and then you've got
a choice of how much solar you are
sharing you do which could well be zero
but if you do it you get to reduce the
climate risk more quickly and and here's
where I think there's a possibility of a
more hopeful outcome not a perfect
outcome not a risk-free outcome but a
more hopeful at them because this
outcome gets you to be able to reduce
climate risk substantially in one
lifetime and it commits you over a few
lifetimes - to a complicated balancing
of Geo sharing and carbon removal that's
not a great answer but it's not like we
have other choices so here's what other
people tend to say about this idea
and I can find a lot worse but I want to
close with thinking through like there's
there's a lot worse out there go go look
maybe some of you think a lot worse so I
want to close with kind of getting at
some of the key underlying concerns I
think the biggest single concern is this
idea of addiction that once you start
the drug of offsetting climate risk
addiction is inevitable no matter how
much we plan a sound strategy the next
generation will just mess it up by only
doing gon sure ain't doing nothing to
cut emissions I think in some ways that
is my biggest fear my fear of talking
about this
well yes but does that mean we'd be
better concealing the fact that solar
chiona sharing might actually
meaningfully reduce risks for people now
living which i think is a moral
imperative I don't think so we've tried
that just say no approach for both teen
sex and drugs and it doesn't work very
well perhaps the best way to influence
the future is to build a social and
political and technical basis for a
plausible strategy that actually gets us
to a soft landing from climate not a
perfect strategy and not a strategy
where whoever works on now that whatever
we think now whatever I've showed you
tonight will certainly not be what we do
over a hundred years but you still have
to start with a coherent strategy so I
think that's the central concern is
really this addiction concern oh sorry I
didn't have an addiction up there the
second core one is is there risks there
are lots of technical risks we can get
to them more in questions but the key
thing to understand is it there's no
risk free choice here the underlying
question is is the world a little bit
safer when save 400 parts per million of
co2 in the air what we have now or with
400 million parts per million of co2 in
the air and a little bit of solar
geoengineering
they're both risky we don't have the
choice to go back to zero
if we had built a civilization without
carbon emissions maybe we'd found
nuclear power early or some magic solar
system we had no carbon emissions and
somebody suddenly found coal and said oh
it's cheaper than our existing energy
system yeah it kills a million people a
year and it'll change the climate is
cheaper than somebody else's yeah we
could fix some of the problem by solar
dream of sharing u-lock such a person up
is insane but we can't magically stop
emitting today people's lives depend on
it
we can stop pretty quickly if we want to
but we can't suddenly go back so our
actual choice today is risk of having
the amount of co2 we have or that plus
geoengineering and it's not obvious
which is less risky I'm not claiming I
know for sure but there are reasons to
take seriously idea that it's less risky
that we're somehow pushing the climate
less hard less radiative forcing in the
words of the climate scientists if we
have some geoengineering and that's the
core trade-off so yes there are real
risks about you are hearing but it's not
a free choice it's a risk risk choice
politics is essential risk so there's
some evidence that Chinese leadership is
worried now about the gradual weakening
of their monsoon strength and one way
they might increase that monsoon
strength is to do one of those forms of
geoengineering the the cloud whitening
off their Shores which cools the ocean a
little bit and monsoons depend on the
temperature contrast between land and
ocean maybe that would make their
monsoon better I'm not saying it would
maybe makes the Indian monsoon worse or
the Indians think it does so what then
you have two states nuclear-armed States
and they're basically fighting like frat
boys over where the thermostat should be
set and we have not only do we not know
what the right answer is as a species we
don't have any of the right mechanisms
to settle disputes like that in place
and those political questions about how
we control this in a deeply divided
world are I think central concerns so
yes they are what's my but I think my
but is that if you think about my
colleagues at Harvard's Belford Center
who spent
a lot of their careers thinking about
the control of nuclear weapons or
financial systems that in some ways
solar jewelry doesn't look that hard
it's hard but we control lots of high
leverage fast-acting things and we don't
do a great job but we do it and in many
ways this thing looks like the benefits
are pretty evenly distributed the costs
are pretty low and as a sort of social
science political problem you can make
an argument that it's easier than many
we already deal with the big last one is
that it's unnatural
this bill mckibben put it that doing
this is in some way the end of nature I
think that's valid and we can come back
to that a little bit more in questions I
have a last quote that I have used
before on these this is from Tom
shelling and Nobel prize-winner really
thoughtful guy on on this topic over
decades this is from the 1982 National
Academy report another National Academy
reported on this table that came out
just a few days ago but this key thing
he says is that once you get going
worrying about co2 and developed a
technology for modifying the climate
then that interested modifying the
climate may flourish whatever we do
about co2 and that gets to me at this
core kind of end of nature concern that
even if my interest in the interest of
many other people now developing this
technology is reducing environmental
impacts once you let this thing loose
people may decide that they want the
environment different that they want to
optimize it in some different way and I
think that coming the answers we can't
bind the future but that is a very
legitimate and concerning outcome so
back to a few pretty pictures from that
same trip in Antarctica it's common to
see the idea of Gina sharing is a sign
of impatience a product of impatience
impatience with the hard labor of
rebuilding the world's energy system to
eliminate carbon emissions in patients
with the difficulty of developing the
social consensus we need to spend the
money to cut in
in patients with global climate politics
the impatience of the kind of Silicon
Valley capitalists who imagine that
every problem can be easily fixed with a
technological solution so a standard
view about reassuring is that the reason
people like samey take it seriously as
were impatient and I think there's some
element of truth in each of these
critiques the presence of a short term
palliative will distract us from the
hard task of cutting emissions or at
least there's a real reason to be
concerned that it is but I think I've
shown you that if you want to do this in
any way it's a hundred or a couple
hundred year process doing it requires a
kind of long patience and planetary
management that is in fact novel and is
more or less as hard as simply the task
of cutting emissions patients is in fact
part of the game if we're gonna do this
seriously patients to experiment
patients to measure what happens
patients to adjust patients to balance
the amount of solar Gina sure and we do
against the amount we cut emissions
those are inherently slow choices and I
think the hopeful answer is that the
combination of cutting emissions to zero
being able to make a negative emissions
to pull co2 out of the atmosphere and
doing some solar generation hearing
gives us a pathway to a soft landing
where we leave the natural world a
little bit more the way we found it and
have less impact on the poor and
vulnerable now and I think that's
something that that is more that is more
viable as a as a pathway forward that
that excites people and that you can
build a socially cohesive answer around
and to me that is the underlying reason
to be excited here that the slogan that
says let's lose more slowly is just not
the right one and we need to think about
slogans not many of you know there's a
so-called 350.org daddy that we should
should have stopped the amount of carbon
acts in the air at 350 parts per million
well I'd prefer 270 org which is the
pre-industrial or zero radiative forcing
Network you can tell I'm not a PR person
but the idea is why don't we aim as a
species at restoration why don't we aim
at bringing the climate back towards
pre-industrial and this gives us one of
the key tools we need to do it thank you
have a seat well I get my skinny legs
back into wakefulness soon
you mentioned reducing carbon in the
atmosphere a couple times and the sort
of in passing is mostly been talking
about solar radiation management say a
little more about carbon capture which
you have a whole other career in as I
understand yes so there's there's a lot
of ways that you could make a negative
emissions or take co2 out of the
atmosphere for example you can grow
biofuels grow grow wood or whatever and
burn it in a way that captures the co2
and puts it underground or you could
just bury the biofuels you could add
alkalinity to the ocean basically co2 is
a weak acid you could add a base to the
ocean which is the long term thing that
the environment wants to do naturally
that's okay never heard of acidification
being somehow fixed because the you know
the the sort of horrible side effect of
your doing the solar radiation
management and aerosols and stratosphere
is that doesn't do anything about
acidification you saying so let's see if
from the geochemical perspective forget
humans co2 comes out and what it does is
it warms the climate up it accelerates
weathering you know the weathering of
rocks washes them down towards the ocean
and those rocks include some some basis
that neutralize the acid in the co2 and
that's the long-run way that the
environment would get rid of in any way
left to itself that process is well
there's several timescales but runs to
millions of years but there are plenty
of methods that we know about today that
would allow you to accelerate them I run
a little startup company that works on
direct capture of co2 from atmosphere
and an industrial process we think about
that
mostly for low carbon fuels in the stack
of no plants or direct capture from the
atmosphere as a way to enable ultra low
carbon fuels is what we're doing 400
parts per million is pretty skinny yes
well energy cost is logarithmic
as you think Wow but but I think the key
point is there are enough ways to do it
and enough of those ways are actually
things that we know how to do at
industrial scale today that I think you
could be certain that barring
civilizational collapse there are ways
we could patiently remove co2 from the
atmosphere over centuries but there's no
way to remove it all really quickly
because of the immense volumes George
Tyson asks what about controllable sky
sales or mirrors rather than
uncontrollable aerosols I actually
started out in this wacky business in 89
little after what when there was an
earlier National Academy report that
proposed a kind of sky sail and didn't
calculate the solar wind forces and
didn't notice all those sales we've
blown out of orbit and so so it
certainly is possible but you have to
think hard as you make the sales very
light because some of you know there's a
thing called a solar sail you make them
very light as you want it for solar
sailing they get blowing quickly out of
orbit and so if you wanted to do it you
have to think about how to do them
stable orbit and there are solutions
that but they're not easy I think you
have to get space travel cheap first and
it's not obvious the aerosol so
stratosphere are such a bad thing so I'm
focused on that but I'm perfectly happy
with more ideas Jim Mason asks what
about the high sulfur coming out of jet
fuel contrails and things like that and
I guess I would ask the the sulfur
dioxide that's you know making it hard
to see down the street in places like
Beijing burning coal has put a whole lot
of sulfur dioxide in the atmosphere not
so much in the stratosphere I guess how
do you compare of aerosols in the
atmosphere versus the stratosphere so we
put about 50 million tons of sulfur in
the lower atmosphere each year kills
about two million people a year let's
say this is from burning principally
coal and some oils and so on so it's a
devastating thing and and one of the
great environmental successes and I mean
if you're gonna have one environmental
celebration last couple years is that
China the world has already turned the
corner
but a few years ago China turn the
corner has begun to drive itself for
emissions down that's a great thing for
the health of people in Beijing and but
it's complicated because actually that's
all for the lower atmosphere is masking
some of the climate warming from co2 so
this is the global dimming or something
yeah I mean in a way nature left the
trap for us by having fossil fuels have
both carbon and sulfur in them because
we happily burn them that burning
releases co2 which in the long run
drives climate warming but that's a
long-term thing the co2 stays for
hundreds of years
sulfur just stays in the atmosphere when
you burn in lamas here for a week or two
but the problem is if we burn it
continuously a bunch of the warming
potential warming from the co2 in the
air is masked by the sulfur cooling and
so manag addiction algae is very close
if we suddenly stop we're going to see
even more warming than we see today
so remember back when this is when Paul
Crutzen sort of came out for
geoengineering because he was noticing
we work gradually but steadily cleaning
up the the emissions in the atmosphere
and that that was going to lead to more
solar coming in and staying man so you
know what's the nature of the offset so
one of the obvious ways to if you sort
of most salesmanship way to say you
should do solar generation in your turn
is to say let's not do any added aerosol
geoengineering so if the current
aerosols are let's say reflecting one
watt per square meter we should take
them out of lower atmosphere where
they're killing two million people a
year right and put a much smaller amount
because you need much less than
stratosphere so maybe 50 times smaller
amount of sulfur in the stratosphere
one-fiftieth in the stratosphere has the
effect oh yes 50 times that in the and
and the health impacts are about 30
times less it turns out per ton so so so
if you wanted to just leave everything
the same no change in the climate
forcing mmm-hmm that we have now but
reduce the deaths from sulfur that would
be one argument for doing geoengineering
okay how bad this again this is I guess
back to Christians worried if we clean
up the atmosphere but don't put
something balancing in the stratosphere
how much are we accelerating or heating
problem if you remove everything it
makes it sort of a factor of two worse
round numbers that is roughly half of
the warming signature of along with
greenhouse gases is now canceled out by
these reflectors okay one of the
chemical effects sulfur dioxide in the
atmosphere killing all these people the
stuff in the status for your gonna be
killing some number of people that are
gonna be sacrifice it's it's an obvious
concern and especially actually do you
think about it sort of morally the the
moral consequences of action as opposed
to inaction I think are different
they're different in most religions and
in law so as I've started to work on
this topic I started to scratch my head
about what would be the health
consequences of putting sulfur in a
stratosphere we've actually just
finished a big three year long study you
have a paper under review on this topic
mm-hmm and the answer was surprising but
the bottom line answer is the direct
impacts of the sulfur you put in the
stratosphere are tiny that kind of
thirty to one number but there's all
these indirect effects some good some
bad that just come from changing the
climate indirect effects on human health
Jill tarter you've got quite an audience
here says you talked about geo solar
engineering or other types of
geoengineering out there and is there
feedback possible for those as well I
mean there's the ones about sort of
advising sea water and maybe enhancing
the strata strivers clouds over the
ocean and that so so there's a whole
there's a whole bunch of ways that one
might change the reflectivity of the
planet from different combats in the
stratosphere to this idea of yet making
certain kinds of marine clouds there's
evidence that we could make them whiter
by putting say fine sea salt aerosol in
there are several other ideas as well I
think it's easy to geek out on the
subtle differences between them the big
picture is all these ideas are kind of
similar they all fundamentally about
masking there all of our aerosols
they're all imperfect they're all quick
the term albedo justement is starting to
be used or something like that I'll be
though being reflectivity yeah and
that's
one thing I sort of like about that is
it puts you outside the earth looking
back you know the reflecting factors
let's make it a little brighter in terms
of the sunlight do you have a where's
your comfort with terminology these days
I sharing it's an ugly word but I think
it's some ways that's a good thing and I
think it's not that I don't want to try
and change the wording because then it
for lots of reasons I think it's hard to
do um Tony Bernhard ash do you assume
uniform dispersal of the aerosols over
the earth and what if you started say
just in the Arctic is once described
this sort of a closed system compared to
the rest of the planet no we don't
assume uniform and we've begun to do
numerical experiments looking at
changing distributions of aerosols to
get to do some tuning of the radiative
forcing three or four things or the
amount we're pushing the climate mm-hm
and there certainly are ways in which
you could tune things to try and
emphasize the specific effect so as you
saw I travel a lot in the Arctic I think
a lot about the Arctic sea ice and and
there are ways you could adjust it to
try and get more effect on Arctic sea
ice and relatively less change to
climates in the in the mid latitudes I
think in general for pretty obvious
political reasons I think the simplest
solution is the one where you just try
and work on the whole climate a very
small amount and the you know the
incremental testing the hundred grams of
sulfur that's gonna give you enough data
you think to start getting feedback on
what's working and not working for some
of the key chemistry yes and that's
because chemistry in the stratosphere is
kind of fundamentally local all the big
chemicals are destroy ozone and they all
have a strong daily cycle I actually
died that so called radicals are all
gone I eat in the day and so you just
get two diurnal cycles the key chemicals
you learn a lot don't learn ever they be
learning I think there's a whole host of
these tests you could do that are small
that allow you to kind of learn your way
up but it's of course true that none of
these things
tell you everything you want to know and
no matter how much you test and how much
you study there will be deep
uncertainties about exactly what the
effects are how much do you think he
needs to do before you get an actual
surface temperature or feedback pens how
that's how heavy a hammer you use so to
speak so if you did this slow rap that I
proposed mm-hmm then feedback I mean you
don't really see effects you could
measure in global surface temperature
for more than a decade or two quite a
long time but I had there but but I
think this is important to say but if
there were the thing we're worried about
is not that it won't be perfect that
global surface I'm worried about some
unknown unknown some unusual feedback in
the stratosphere that makes somehow the
ozone loss much worse or puts more water
to transfer and some of that we can
detect with much higher signal-to-noise
notice we could detect that much earlier
mm-hmm and I think that's one of the
reasons to think about a slow monitored
deployment and what's your sense of the
and the one of the great things about is
is in the sense the whole world is now
understanding increasingly that
everybody's dealing with this global
problem it is a global problem and it's
a colbrunn problem in a way unlikely say
the Cold War the nuclear confrontation
where of us sort of solved by people in
secret rooms in just a couple of
governments this has to be solved by
basically everybody or enough of
everybody that it can make a difference
and so one of the things that people say
as well you can't really do any of this
until everybody agrees to do it is that
the case no sometimes we wish it was the
case a couple comets first of all why
have we made some little progress on
climate you know as I said the core
sides have been known for decades an
obvious answer is that various interests
including corporate interest and the
fossil fuel companies want to stop it
and they certainly have acted
ugly ways to frustrate action but that
can't be a sufficient explanation
because all sorts of other environmental
pollutants air and water lead mercury
DDT we made real progress on in the last
50 years in the especially the the more
rich parts of the world real progress in
some cases really turned the corner not
made the problem go away but made it get
a lot less bad even while we've had
economic growth and in all those cases
there was opposition in politics and
uncertainty about the science and false
uncertainty by the science hmm so why
have we made progress in so many things
like that and not climate I start this
whole class on environmental politics at
Harvard on that topic and I think the
reason is the way that climate is this
collective action problem at global
scale I mean if I spend money as I did
in my house to insulate it better I get
some benefit from that but the the
climate benefits go globally and 100 or
200 years out and and that is the core
asymmetry that makes it so hard to get a
deal on climate and that that won't go
away mm-hmm here's one of several
questions from Andrew Marshall you've
said that solar radiation management
involves annual spraying of 20,000 tons
of forecasted under the app stratosphere
you said atmosphere you've confirmed
this will cause 10,000 deaths annually
to believe this isn't acceptable death
rate so no I didn't say that twenty
confusing 20,000 tons doesn't do 10,000
deaths not close the ratio of if you put
a ton of sulfur in the atmosphere with a
current distribution of combustion
sources compared to putting a ton into
the stratosphere the ratio of the direct
health impacts is about 30 to 1 mm-hmm
so it's about 30 times less dangerous
mm-hmm I do think there are real moral
consequences of that risks that are
serious of course the only reason to do
this is if we expect overall it's
healthy overall it reduces risk to
people including risks of say heat waves
so
so but there are trade-offs that are
hard one of the things I've started
looking at geoengineering a term that
came up is a sort of a scare term was
you lateral geoengineering you know what
if rich person what if pissed-off nation
or worried nation just goes ahead and
starts doing it is that a what do you
think of that
what are your political course teach
about the first of all I'd say I'd say
rich person I don't think is credible
for the following reason
that in the end if if there was a rich
person in Europe if we're two countries
there's a rich person in your country
who begins to do it and you say oh it's
not my country just a citizen in my
country felt like doing it mm-hmm I say
I regard the actions of any citizen your
state that effect my state as your
responsibility so I think there's a way
in which this quickly becomes de facto
state action whoever it started so I
think this sort of individual isn't the
issue but there certainly as an issue
was with individual states doing it okay
and you can look at that as a good or
bad thing depending on the outcome if
you imagine a kind of sudden decision by
a non democracy with no consultation
then it looks awful mm-hmm if you
imagine a coalition of a few states that
maybe really span the world with some
from the poor south and some from the me
was joining India yeah and they do it
slowly and it's completely open and they
do it after years of testing and they
appoint an International Commission
that's quite representative to oversee
it then the answer might be that that's
not a bad outcome and that some other
countries would say we deplore this
action that's they say publicly and
privately they say we're glad somebody's
doing this is reducing the climate risk
it we can blame them
Damon asks is there an antidote to h2so4
just in case something wasn't captured
in the models well generally what's the
antidote situation here so I say I mean
the solver this so whatever you put in
the stratosphere gets there is gonna
stay there for a long time a couple
years a year now so I mean first sulphur
the direct health effects I think that
that it's very hard to imagine there
subgiant I know an unknown because it's
what we're already doing it huge scales
we're putting in 50 million tons now
we're talking about one more it's hard
to see there's some unexpected awful
health effect
I think the unexpected awful effects are
stratospheric chemistry just done the
lingering aspect is aerosols lingered
longer in the atmosphere was
stratosphere or really compare if you in
the lower atmosphere
our souls are washed out by rain on a
time scale of about a week okay so some
of China's pollution makes it here
across the Pacific but not that much so
there but there are and I know people
who try to catch fit their Chinese
lately there are Americans who died
because of Chinese pollution and the
Europeans who died because American
pollution but but in the stratosphere
sulfur lasts for a year or two and and I
think that's actually a good amount of
time you you you know this is back for
this pilot induced oscillation one of
the ways I thought about is let's say
it's a design problem let's say you're
designing a box that's the magic knob
for adjusting it mm-hmm
how quickly should that not respond if
if you're adjusting this get pilot
oscillations that you have the wrong way
if you're gonna give that box to some a
very wise calm group of across cultures
and nations who always put their feet up
and think wisely before they add they're
all on the answer is D and yeah then you
know answers you give them a thing that
acts very quickly because they might
want to for some reason but they'll make
the wise choices okay but if you're
actually gonna give this box to real
political class today you might not want
it to act too quickly because maybe
people will sort of accidentally have a
drunken fight and adjust it fast
I'm being glib but but I think there's a
genuine issue of the fact that we do
live in a divided multipolar world and
it's dangerous to develop technologies
that react too quickly and all else
equal you want this thing to be
slow-moving partly because you want to
average out the quick changes of sort of
the political mood at the moment a
couple questions about the models models
were surprised by the rapid melting in
the Arctic it seems like the models were
surprised by the relative plateauing of
surface temperatures increased in the
last 12 or so years what's your sense of
what the deeper lessons are there and
you know what do you think about this
current plateauing is that deep or
perturbation noise one way to measure
how uncertain the models are is what we
call the range and climate sensitivity
in how much the climate changes that we
double co2
the first big estimate was made in 1979
by the Charney Commission and said one
point five to four point five degrees C
for a doubling and what's amazing is we
haven't narrowed that range very much
right since 79 which is a long time ago
and and I think what we found is that
while we've learned a huge amount about
all these specifics huge stacks of
scientific papers and the models are in
many respects much better than they were
in 1979 I'm the first client models that
kind of have a little more data all
sorts of stuff we actually can't predict
with much higher accuracy the kind of
biggest single question which is how
much the climate reacts to a given
amount of co2 in the air and and I think
the reality is we're going to get there
before we know the answer so were you
surprised by this relative slowing of
the heating that happens yes well some
of my colleagues are very worked up
about it I worked up and worked up
either then it has big political
implications because it makes climate
change seem less bad or that it shows
some thing we really don't understand
about the models
my census news pretty random noise and I
don't think you start out by saying
Steve Schneider said that you don't
learn decade and I think it's mostly
noise I'm not sure there's a lot of
signal to pull out there but but I'm not
an expert in that given that if how many
more years with the plateauing go on for
you to decide what signal not noise just
out of here to the master would be 20
starts to worry me a lot more than 10 20
look at this for but that's not that's
just do the ocean all the people I
talked to you I talked a lot of people
about ocean stuff in relation to biology
and they're basically saying this is a
great deep dark mystery which we are
just beginning to get little pieces of
understanding about and this seems to
apply also to what the sort of heat
engine of the ocean actually is and how
it works with currents and depths and
all this kind of stuff
how big a black box is the ocean in
these models that is how many surprises
and maybe including this plateauing or
not I'm not sure is the ocean less
certain and say water vapor in the in
the atmosphere in stratosphere which was
a big question for a long time that
seems to be getting sorted out as the
ocean of that level of mystery or
something worse I think if you're
talking about if you're talking about
predicting specific things in the ocean
obviously the ocean is the big central
piece but if you're talking about
predicting the how much the climate will
change in the middle the continents or
even here say 50 years out or a hundred
years out I think the biggest
uncertainty still really are the core
uncertainties about clouds and water
vapor in the upper part of the tropics
those are the biggest uncertainties that
really drive a lot of this this thing I
just mentioned this uncertainty in the
climate sensitivity and the ocean part
is a relatively small contributor over a
century okay I think the bigger
uncertainties for climate impacts or
they got certainty about how much ice
sheets melt deep but certainty to talk
about albedo shift right so
what's your sense on what happens with
the ice as time goes forward I mean
you've just dropped in there Oh
Greenland basically melts so said a lot
of the conventional models all have a
pretty slow response right and and they
the main set of standard models showed
that you got a huge amount of ice sheet
melting over a thousand years but a
pretty small amount over 100 years and
the main way climate policies worked
which i think is nonsense and they inter
governmental Panel on Climate Change I
dropped out of now it is they typically
said did everything for a hundred years
they effectively assumed that there was
no value after 100 years and I think a
lot of us actually intuitively feel
there's a lot of value after 100 years
but in any case the standard models all
have ice sheets reacting very slowly but
there's increasing evidence that they
can react quickly we've seen
observational evidence in Greenland of
much faster outflows say of the the
glaciers that flowed at a disco Bay on
the west reman are flowing much faster
you can see that from satellite radar
and there's evidence that the surface is
melted faster than we expected and and
so if you
that's real uncertainty and the extreme
views of that suggest that we really
might be wrong you might be able to get
substantial deglaciation and century and
a half or so and that would really be a
big deal yeah more than more than a
meter sea level rise but they're also
thoughtful people to say more than
another sea level or ice and what kind
of time for him they're certainly
sensible people who work on green and I
think green that alone could get you a
meter in a century it isn't a century
century and what's the acceleration that
happens when sea ice turns to see which
zero well I mean you know in terms of
reflectance oh yes so I mean I use my
ski this ice is readily reflective and
I'm told that open sea water is about as
absorbent as a asphalt parking lot or
something yeah the Arctic is melting
fast
especially summertime see Isis
everybody's seen is going away quickly
and that's an example of a surprise it's
gonna be quicker than most models
pretend that becomes then an accelerator
the whole process or not yeah there's
certainly a feedback there but but if
you think about your hearing or cutting
emissions that's something which has
less inertia so there's a lot of
evidence that if we did some Jewish
hearing or we're able to bring emissions
or concentrations down quickly the sea
ice itself responds fast but it's only
lives for a few years whereas the
glaciers the big ice sheets are in
Antarctica or Greenland are a much
slower process and it's interesting so
one of the early signs of quote success
with solar radiation management with
sulfates in the atmosphere or in the
stratosphere would be that the sea ice
would in the winter yeah wreak immense
it sold rain and the small and the small
glacier so on that ski trip actually we
were skiing along North Baffin Island
and then topo maps are all based on
1950s air photos Canon doesn't you know
we don't we don't go back and do that
very often topo maps not Arctic and so
the topo maps all have these glaciers
and we'd ski each day by a bunch of
these big outflow glaciers from
agreement from a North Baffin and those
glaciers are all back many kilometres
from where they were and it's quite
something to see that I mean that trip
was a recreational or therapeutic trip
it wasn't about science but you can't
help looking at all those glaciers being
melted that far back and really be
stunned Kevin Kelly yes does carbon
sequestration not scale and comparison
with sulphate shading they're just
completely different things so this
sulphate shading idea is something that
is inherently temporary it's it it acts
in the short-term year by year
but it does nothing I mean in a sense
they cutting emissions or taking co2 out
of the air works on this long-term
flywheel that's like this one hundred or
thousand year mmm
flywheel of the carbon content of the
atmosphere
and in the end if you don't manage the
carbon content of the atmosphere you
don't have a safe climate mm-hmm all
this sulfate or whatever you do for
solar to your hearing helps to mask some
of the risk that could be good there's a
reason we have bad dates but but it
operates fundamentally on a short time
scale so the good thing you can say is I
think it's fair to say the only way that
we know about that you could
substantially reduce the climate risk in
one lifetime is solar generation earing
mm-hmm but on the other hand no amount
of solar generation rain changes the
long-term risk of co2 accumulating in
the atmosphere well you see all these
trends and you've been out there on the
ground actually or in the water in some
of these places you know there's always
the optimistic pessimistic oh let me try
realistic what's your realistic sense of
how this is gonna play out ooh shake of
the head yeah that's a little worried
I'm I think the humans will protect
themselves for a firm least natural
fluctuations especially wealthier humans
but I really do fear that will turn the
natural world in an artifact and pave it
over fast and I view this as partly an
attempt this is many ways to give our
great-grandkids more of a chance to see
more of the natural world that we
inherited and evolved from which is deep
in us and people need so that's one of
things that really motivates me I think
they want key thing people have idea
that all of these attempted
interventions always fail and he can
think of lots of examples from cane
toads or Australian monkeys in Hawaii
they were introduced to control the rats
there's lots of these examples that have
failed there's actually lots that have
succeeded too and if you think people's
view about whether they all fail or
succeed shows people's kind of
underlying pessimism
our optimism but there's no objective
answer okay and and there are plenty of
times we've done a combination of of
dealing with the root problem and then a
technical fix on top so in fact my my
parents were involved in peregrine
falcon reproduction as a kid I actually
helped a little bit we had peregrine
falcons in my basement and we're
releasing them on boxes in this place in
Ottawa my father had been involved in
getting dvt banned and so so we really
did both strategies with peregrine
falcons we dealt with the root problem
which was organochlorine pesticides
cascading in the food chain yeah but we
dealt with it slowly but we also had an
artificial program the breed peregrine
falcon
we the artificial way under under
prairie falcons in a controlled
environment and then reintroduce them in
so-called hack boxes that would Falconer
scald them all over North America and
that helped to make the Falcons come
back more quickly and does that mean
that it's all artificial does that mean
that when you see a falcon now today
it's a complete artefact and it's not
natural well you could argue that at an
extreme case but I think the answer is
that we we must take responsibility for
them for trying to manage the natural
world that we have mangled in case you
were you treated both the symptom in the
cause the cause being the DDT in the
symptom being by the way do I have any
birds left so that's like CDR and SRM
about carbon carbon removal and solar
Jimmy sure you can make this right
here's a way to say it a guy called Bill
Clark one of my mentors in this business
I talked about this and I think first
and 89 or something I heard him talk on
algae or hearing and he said that we we
have to admit that we're we're in the
gardening business with the planet
whether we like it or not
the question is whether we're going to
pretend we're not and have a messy
garden where we just let our
refrigerators and old tires out in the
backyard and fill it with with with
trash or whether we get serious about
taking responsibility for it and weeding
it than managing it but at this point we
can't claim to be a little tiny thing
against a big wilderness I've been
privileged to see some at wilderness but
humanity is a monstrous
on the planet and if we want to maintain
some of the natural beauty and and and
biological integrity we have to be
conscious about it mm-hmm and I think
there are lots of ways in which that's
happening at the level of national parks
or ideas like Yellowstone - Yukon and I
see being conscious about managing the
radiative forcing of the atmosphere that
the climate change as being a weird and
large and unprecedented part of the same
story
we are as gardeners and have to get good
at it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]